dear prime minister adern dear president
macron
ladies and gentlemen the attack during
the
friday prayer on the 15th of march
2019 will always remain a terrible scar
in the history of new zealand it gave
rise to worldwide shock
not only the attack itself but also the
way
life images spread on the internet
the online space of freedom and
connection
was all of a sudden cynically
used to spread hate
the attack in christ church reminded us
of the harmful role the internet
can play online terrorist content
can motivate new attacks radicalize
people and disseminate
dangerous technical know-how it should
have
no place on the internet and as the
president of the european commission
i feel my responsibility in stopping
terrorist and violent extremist content
from spreading
but even an organization as determined
as the european union
cannot address this issue alone
and this is why i value so much our
meeting today
it brings together all those who are
part of the solution
governments tech companies civil
societies
we need cooperation 24 7 communication
channels
and crisis protocols and we also need
solid safeguards to protect freedom of
speech
because once we sacrifice our freedom
in the fight against terror terrorists
will have achieved their ultimate goal
with the christ church call for action
we've improved our collaboration and our
response
we are all working together under the
global internet forum to counter
terrorism and we now have an eu crisis
protocol
allowing us to respond immediately and
together
in an emergency in order to stop new
terrorist content from spreading
sadly enough we had to activate it
after the murder of samuel patti in
france
voluntary cooperation brings results it
needs to continue
but that alone is not always enough
governments also have the responsibility
to create
fail-safe tools that address the most
harmful content
immediately and this is why in the
european union
we've decided to go further with our
digital services act
we make clear that online platforms
must take greater responsibility for
their role
in disseminating and promoting such
material
and in addition the european union just
recently adopted a new regulation
on removing terrorist content online
it obliges online platforms to take down
terrorist content
within the hour anywhere in the european
union
and today i want to invite our friends
from all over the world to work together
because terrorism is a global threat
and it can only be beaten with a global
answer
after the attacks on the al-nur and
linwood mosques
new zealanders truly inspired the world
in how they refuse to answer violence
and hatred
with division and more hatred
their message was they are us
we are one kota too
tattoo in maori
these words remind us that we must stand
together
we have to do more and we have to start
earlier
we need to prevent terrorism from
appearing in the first place
and this is why we need to step up our
efforts to prevent radicalization
because no one is born as a terrorist
we have to tackle the root causes of
radicalization
such as social isolation and poverty
we have to build strong communities
where each of us belongs
and no one feels left behind
and we have to fight radical and
distorted ideologies
with positive ideas and alternative
narratives
ladies and gentlemen the internet
connects people
it unites us the internet fosters
debates
it projects citizens voices in our
democracies
it's our responsibility to make sure
it remains that way it's our job
to ensure it is not misused
you can count on europe to work together
with you
and to move forward together thank you
very much for your attention